la stratégie de désengorgement des
prisons et yoko vie 19 est elle
applicable sur le long terme ça c'est la
grosse question est là l'intérêt cette
stratégie c'est que l a démontré qu'il
était tout à fait possible d'avoir un
nombre de détenus inférieur en utilisant
d'autres peines que la peine de prison
ferme et l'incarcération sait on à 60000
places de prison en france et on était
arrivés pratiquement à 70 milles avant
l'épisode de koh vide on avait baissé
pratiquement à 60 milles et l'a à
nouveau
on a encore des matelas par terre des
personnes qui sont trois dans une
cellule deux ans maintenant et c est ce
qui s'est passé pendant le coït compte
tenu de l'état sanitaire des prisons est
bien c'est qu'on a trouvé d'autre
solution que la peine de prison ferme et
sèche
c'est à dire qu'on a mis les gens en
liberté avec un bracelet électronique
avec un suivi qui s'appelle assure si
par exemple mise à l'épreuve
beaucoup décidé les juges d'application
des peines bref d'autres manières de
punir que simplement enfin quelqu'un
dans une cellule donc voilà la stratégie
je pense à suivre pour l'avenir
mon